this is 21 years in the making this
dream of mine I thought of the title The
Perks of Being a Wallflower
yeah 21 years ago this coming November
when I was a student at USC and and I
always thought it was gonna be a book
and I always dreamt it would be a movie
and I knew that it was we had to just I
to be really really careful to do it
right you know that some things you
don't develop you can't you have to
write it and write it and write it and
write it on spec until it's right until
it's ready I just learned so much over
the years you know rent got made in the
Jericho got on the air which was great
but I've been working I've been writing
a journeyman screenwriter for a long
time and I'd worked for so many great
directors from you know starting with
Griffin Don I did this coming-of-age
movie for him and Miramax years ago and
he was so nice and then Spike Lee was
the first director on rent and then
Chris Columbus Jon Turteltaub obviously
and for Jericho but then Jay Roach I
wrote a thing it didn't go but you pick
up like how I don't know these guys they
seem to have a way of navigating the
waters in a way that I didn't understand
when I was younger
so I really studied them and I also
studied all the the TV kind of the
journeyman TV directors that came on
Jericho and you watch how they work and
you see how they talk to actors and I
was a sponge it was it was the greatest
grad school you could have asked for to
sit there and watch and realize that
there's so many different styles of
making films and just to be true to your
own for this because I wanted to make a
vid to make as much of a timeless movies
I could make so I went back to the
classic classics starting with rebel
that a cause which I loved and the
graduate of course in Harold and Maude
and stand by me and Dead Poets Society
those five movies more than anything
else got me through adolescence and and
in ways I will never discuss on a stage
and but also inspired me as a filmmaker
and as a young student you know
especially reveled out a cause because
the screenwriters Stuart Stern and he
Melissa don't let me go off on the rails
on Stuart Stern but but Stuart has been
my mentor since I was 19 and and he's
the first person who read this
screenplay and gave me notes
and so he's 90 years old now I lives up
in Seattle and I showed him the movie a
couple of weeks ago and we shared we
shared a stage and did a Q&A together it
was pretty much the greatest moment of
my life a lot of this story is very
personal to me so between my own
experience and writing the novel and
writing the screenplay
I knew the essence of each person that I
wanted to cast and it was really
important to me because I'm kind of a
gentle guy that I wanted yes I wanted
great actors of course first and
foremost but I also needed really great
people like nice you know team players
that that that of course they would love
their roles but they would love you know
they would see a part as a part of a
whole you know and that were excited
about this story and telling this story
we had great casting in Pittsburgh local
we had some New York as well in the
extras I got to tell you one thing I
learned about extras and and also what
what first IDs do and second ATS do
because it's such invisible work in a
lot of ways and and they deserve a lot
more credit than they get is those kids
at in the capitate like when the kids
are fighting the cafeteria fight yeah to
me because I was like I had Logan I've
Ezra I I'm feel good about these guys
they were doing a great job but you look
around and just the sense of reality
those other kids brought to it or
brought to the football game are brought
to the the diner I don't know that they
really helped because they really helped
make it feel real to me I wanted to make
a timeless almost a timeless nostalgic
movie and I thought I had an opportunity
because of when the book is said it's
set in the early 90s to make a film
about young people in the last moment
before the Internet and the cell phone
changed communication not adolescence to
me at all but but communication because
now it's like my daughter was born
literally six weeks ago on Friday and I
think about what she's going to go
through and the fact that all of my
stupid mistakes I made at parties
they're not on YouTube you know and and
although now they're in the movie so I
don't really know what I was trying to
get away with but I feel that the
pressure that puts on kids and I want I
thought it would be really valuable to
to make a movie that showed that there
was this there was this moment before
that happened
and that and that and to show that
adolescence itself does not change
because my hope is with the movie and my
secret mission was to make a film that
that a young person could love because
it validates and respects what they're
going through but simultaneously they're
their folks might feel nostalgic about
and if this girl in her mom or this boy
in her and his dad can love the same
movie for a different reason maybe
they'll talk a little bit more and maybe
some of the things that this person is
keeping secret will will get aired out
and they might have a shot at a better
life a lot earlier than I did